O
IT.
THAT MAY BE THE REAL REFERENCE
OF AFGHANISTAN AND LET'S HOPE
OUR LEADERS NOTICE IT.
A RETIRED ARMY COLONEL AND
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE ENTRANCES
TONIGHT BECAUSE HE IS THE ONE
MAN WHO CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHO SHOULD HAVE KNOWN BETTER?
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
SO YOU HAVE CALLED FOR
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN FOR
A LONG TIME, GAVE THEM A
DETAILED PLAN FOR HOW TO DO THAT
WITHOUT THE RESULT WE ARE SEEING
TODAY.
WHAT DID OUR GOVERNMENT AND JUST
DO THAT WE SHOULD NOT HAVE DONE?
>> I THINK THERE ARE THREE
THINGS WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION.
FIRST, OF COURSE, IS THERE WAS
NEVER AN EXIT STRATEGY.
WHEN I WAS IN THE PENTAGON, THE
ONLY THING I COULD FIND OUT WAS
THERE WAS INTENTION TO STAY
INDEFINITELY.
FOR SOME OF THE REASONS YOU
OUTLINED IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS, LOTS OF PEOPLE WERE
BENEFITING.
NOT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
CERTAINLY NOT OUR SOLDIERS AND
MARINES, BUT THERE WAS NO PATH
OUT OF THE PLACE.
SECONDLY, THESE TOXIC SENIOR
MILITARY LEADERS BECAUSE THEY
SIMPLY DON'T TELL THE TRUTH AND
FOR 20 YEARS, THEY'VE BEEN LYING
FRANKLY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
TO SOLDIERS AND MARINES DOING
THE FIGHTING TELLING THEM THINGS
WERE GETTING BETTER, THAT WE
WERE MAKING PROGRESS WHEN THE
TRUTH WAS WE WEREN'T.
AND THE SOLDIERS AND MARINES CAN
BE BLAMED FOR THAT.
LET THERE BE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT
BUT THE GENERALS HAVE DONE A
TERRIBLE JOB AND IT IS OBVIOUS
FROM WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ON THE
GROUND RIGHT NOW, THE CHAOS.
NO PLANNING, NO PREPARATION,
AWFUL.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING WORSE.
AND FINALLY, WE WENT IN AND SAID
WE WERE GOING TO FIGHT TERRORISM
WHICH HE SAID WAS OVER QUITE
QUICKLY, NO REASON TO MAKE WAR,
HAD NO ROLE IN 9/11, WE WERE
THERE FROM AL QAEDA ONLY
AL QAEDA ESCAPE THROUGH THE
INCOMPETENCE OF OTHERS BUT
EFFECTIVELY, WE HAVE PUSH THEM
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN AND WE SHOULD
HAVE.
WE DIDN'T DO THAT AND SO WHAT
HAVE WE GOT NOW?
WE DON'T HAVE DEMOCRACY, WE
HAVEN'T DEFEATED TERRORISM, WE
HAVE PROBABLY CREATED SOME NEW
ONES, WE HAVE THE LARGEST NARCO
STATE IN THE WORLD NOW FALLING
INTO THE HANDS OF NEW CRIMINALS
AND NEW TERRORISTS.
>> Tucker: ALL OF THAT IS
DEPRESSING TO HEAR AND I THINK
VERIFIABLY TRUE BUT I WANT TO GO
TO THE VERY FIRST POINT THAT YOU
MADE THAT AFTER 20 YEARS, THERE
IS NO SPECIFIC PLAN TO LEAVE HER
AS YOU PUT IT, GLIDE PAST.
HOW COULD THAT BE?
>> WHEN WE FIRST WENT INTO IRAQ,
THERE WAS AN ARGUMENT BETWEEN
SOME OTHERS IN HIS OFFICE AND
FINALLY INTERJECTED AND SAID WE
JUST WANT TO GET THE ARMY INTO
IRAQ.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT DECIDED THEY JUST
WANTED TO GET THE MILITARY INTO
THESE PLACES AND THAT SOMEHOW OR
ANOTHER, WE WOULD MUDDLE
THROUGH, THAT THINGS WOULD
IMPROVE.
A GENERATION ENDS WHEN IT'S
ILLUSIONS ARE EXHAUSTED.
I THINK IT WAS ARTHUR MILLER
THAT SAID THAT.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING NOW ON
TELEVISION, THIS MASS CHAOS AND
DISSOLUTION IS THE END OF THE
ILLUSIONS THAT BEGAN LONG AGO IN
THE AFTERMATH OF DESERT STORM
WITH HER SUCCESSORS.
WHY ARE WE USING THE ARMY?
YOU KEEP TALKING ABOUT HOW GOOD
IT IS, LET'S USE IT.
HE OBVIOUSLY WAS NOT EXCITED
ABOUT SEEING IT EMPLOYED FOR
REASONS OTHER THAN FIGHTING.
WELL, WE HAVE EMPLOYED IT ALL
OVER THE MIDDLE EAST AND WHAT
HAVE WE CREATED?
CHAOS.
WHAT HAVE WE ESTABLISHED IN THE
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
NOTHING.
>> Tucker: RECKLESS CHILDREN
AND Y